est-ce que vous avez vu qu'à une actu
qui a fait énormément réagir c'est des
fêtards verbalisées en pleine nuit pour
trouble du voisinage et non respect du
confinement
c'est dans lequel valeureuse des jeunes
ont organisé une fête dans le quartier
résidentiel qui n'a pas plu aux voisins
rappelé à l'ordre plusieurs fois ils ont
finalement été verbalisé pour tapage
nocturne non respect du confinement par
les gendarmes
et sur twitter la gendarmerie du
calvados a relayé cette information tout
en faisant passer un message
restez chez vous voilà donc il est vrai
quoi là c'était il ya deux ans il jaunit
l'ont fait et ils ont fait la fiesta
quoi voilà vous vous êtes pâte avec vos
voisins
sophie cost a déjà eu une aventure avec
un hôte et voisin j'ai pas eu une
aventure avec un de mes voisins mais moi
je suis très pote avec ma voisine à 95
ans qui vit seul et mettez voisine avec
jean avec isabelle morini bosc
non mais elle est trop mignonne
sauf que dès que je les adresse la
parole elle me parle prend trois arbres
qui avaient chuté ces courses voilà jean
d'amour bravo bravo j'ai été traitée
moyen doit alors je suis très copain
avec le voisin d'en face qui est génial
dans le reste de l'immeuble c'est un peu
plus compliqué alors mon principe c'est
que détient à bruit je descends où je
monte je vais voir je tombe à la
compétition s'il vous plaît et à la
donne comme d'habitude c'est mauvais
alors quel mauvais je vous le dis ja je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué
c'est vrai que dès qu'on arrive dans un
immeuble qu'on commence à déménager il
ya un petit peu mais une petit coup de
pression parce que yara voisins et a
toujours un voisin qui vont montrer que
c'est lui le chef un petit peu de
l'immeuble n'ont pas un genre qui
commence à rêver et et oui il ya
toujours un moyen qui veut te mettre un
petit coup de chaud près du genre c'est
vous qui avez laissé les poubelles
monsieur il veut toujours te faire un
petit coup de pression tu vas donc je
voulais le voir c'est ce que je fais à
chaque fois que j'arrive dans un
immeuble il faut prendre un minimum
là vous lui mettez tout de suite à des
coups très son voile a voulu dit voilà
écoute je suis là
s'il ya une bagarre voilà je te le dis
je suis pas là pour me faire marcher sur
les pieds mais surtout ce que vous
pouvez faire si vous invitez tout le
monde chez vous le premier jour ils
pourront pas en ce moment où ces
périodes de confinement est là tous les
invités et ça boit et du manga et du bo
gars et du fanta et de l'orangina et des
tuques et des trucs tu les fais qui fait
et après frérot et tu leur dis tu aimes
pas qui fait tu peux faire une fête tous
les soirs tu étais au parquet hier
et là frère tu les as dans la poche vrai
ou pas il faut faire une fête avec tous
les voisins directs
sinon je te le dis tu vas te faire
marcher sur les papattes vrai ou pas
castaldi bien sûr bien tu t'es déjà en
brouille avec un 3 1 de la vérité ah oui
alors j'ai une super histoire
avant j'habitais juste en face d'un
célèbre musiciens le guitariste de
téléphone
bertignac dans l'autre 2011 oui mais
c'est un amour comme toi non non l'autre
au wild center et jolie aubert est en
fait moi je faisais beaucoup de travaux
dans ma maison et un jour il est
débarqué genre bien 8 9 heures du matin
et avec les cheveux complètement comme
ça et met en faute est tout petit il en
dit baba il ya une sorcière qui veulent
arriver dans le jardin a laissé son père
algérien on y va du côlon est et a déjà
craqué pour un voisin toi j'ai jamais
craqué pour un vanins encore mais ça
peut arriver parce que d'accord tabtabaï
là rien qui te qui peut te chauffer pour
le moment mais j'ai pas exploité tout
l'immeuble tu sais ya quand même de
nombreux étals comme j'ai pas pu le toit
plus avec le confinement et moi bah
écoute tu verra ça après le confinement
à mon avis tu trouvera chaussure à tapas
pattes
qu'est ce qui se passe avec l'aide que
tu m'apportes chaque soir dans
l'émission je pense que oui oui ah bah
oui oh là là vous avez qu elle est
elle est classe laurent seillier des
classes c'est vrai alala